previously on raft the notes notes up
days noose Oh blueprint for an engine or
want an engine oh I want to see this I'm
ready
holy [ __ ] and then the steering wheel
will be right here I feel like we should
be going faster don't seem to be doing
much so do we need multiple engines both
off oh sweet Jesus wait it was off oh
there we go
Oh Balboa one one two six we do have
another we have another heading weird
without 100 meters it's north good thing
we got these engines I think that's
gross that's dope
can we put the steering wheel up here is
that possible oh my gosh this is such a
dangerous place to be
this is the helmsman's position I can't
help you with the shark from up on my
lap I'm sorry this connects all the way
up to the steering wheel whoa what the
freaking whoa can we raise the anchor
and drive around a little
raising anchor I've never done it before
it's very very cool
also I discovered more than one sail
doesn't do anything well it's good that
we have so many then I'm gonna leave
them up just because they look good but
yeah they don't do nothing are the
engines on we get a little engine power
move our I'd like to mention power
please thank you sir you're welcome sir
glad we can all be civil sir old
chugga-lugga head my dude we're chugging
we're logging full ahead
I don't like that I am going to try to
figure out a way to get organized boxes
in here good luck
all right see a beach on our left here
can we get up this Beach promising sir
oh there is a siege we right ah probably
drop anchor I guess stop thank you Wow
that's pretty cool it's this pretty cool
great job everybody we have like no
would Dewey
we'd never know but there's a whole [ __ ]
ton of trees on this island we can
totally cut down you're right and
probably no sharks you're on the island
probably no sharks it does say non Park
personnel must turn back with a picture
of a bear barking nothing I like guess
what we can't chop these trees down
why because well I swing my axe at it no
wood comes out of it home I mean why
obviously where's our cook third cab we
got nothing water is a thing yeah
there's bowls of soup unless someone ate
way too much there should be bowls of
soup all right I'm just gonna come back
to the boat I don't want to I don't want
to explore by myself I want everyone to
see things a dead bird here yeah I shot
it with a room you could probably cook
that good food
you're welcome that's what I'm here for
how do I make never mind I think I can
figure it out I figured it out you put
it on the grill in the fire goes whoosh
and when the fire go fussen you eat it
to be clear your questions gonna be how
do I cook food
the beats are mine the beats they're me
I'll take the beats beats are well we
are out of food huh well you know
someone decided to be a captain and not
a chef anymore and then things kind of
went to Garbo why I know you were all
eating all my food what not there was no
food and then we were not eating we need
clay do we have clay anywhere we have
play we can make things to put the soup
in super should interesting idea clay
it's very strange that you would say
something like we have a whole [ __ ] ton
of glad I know why are being so crazy
about this so much clay right I didn't
know the clay situation why would I be
some 16 bowls cheese all our clay now
there's still clay left don't even worry
about the clay listen I don't know what
I most have so much clay I'm struggling
to adapt to this as wacky feels good
what do you feel not not me I feel so
good I feel so good
do you feel not mean as well feel so
good good very good great good great hey
I just ate a bowl of soup and it's
really helping me out here
all right cool I'm gonna go the island
wait mark are you are you on the island
wait up dead-ass exploring the island
cape and say it's an island it's more
like a continent so really you're the
wrong one but we need more powder
wait you Explorer wait can we explore
explore come on yes way my my food
situation still isn't great my mom away
[Applause]
running up the hill alright so explorer
we all assuming they're gonna be bears
on this island because this suggests I
feel prepared for a bear all right mark
you shoot them you shoot him with some
Rose I've got like two rows it's not
feathers of the problem is the bow
itself is bout to Brooke our bows hard
to make owner can make little waves
intensive air dens ahead you know what
I'm thinking I'm shooting it may be so
to be clear before we wait it looks like
a weapon that's gonna last more than one
hit that is much larger animal than I
would have suspected but if we shoot
okay okay at least disengage what's that
mean I mean it means that we'll continue
to follow you as a limited range yeah I
did learn is that we're faster than it
yeah so dinner right there you want to
go get it you go bag yourself a bear man
from what I gather going this way I
think mark and I have the right
stratagem yeah wait we need
do you did you see the thing with the
wild berries yeah that's what I won we
can we can harvest a chop you catch if
chop the skinny ones yeah the skinny
ones this one's not ship shopping I
don't know man the axe is clearly not
sharp enough or big enough or something
it's not girthy enough mark I found I
found honeycomb you found honey smaller
it's smaller it's smaller it's less
leashed it's Leslie wait help shot I
don't see any weapon I'm going to die no
please wait I'm so scared oh my god he
got it Wade you got it Wade you got it
you got it
Wade I'm so proud of you for your
bravery how you doing mark you hug it
coming I'm coming back okay oh my god we
killed the tiny bear not the big one
feast on its flesh cook it's meeting me
I mean two raw meats and some leather
leather we needed leather for something
I don't know what you mean it they're
dying that's the sound of me dying look
guys there's bees in here that's not
good what are you cold what are you
Columbian I'm harvesting the honeycomb
let's do happen I'm harvesting this
honeycomb let's see what how it's fine
it's fine
okay good I don't trust these bees
they're kind of flying around in a
concerning shape no they're fine are
these these small teensy trees are the
ones you can get there yeah the little
cow spots the Dalmatian ones I got one X
wild bear I see that Oh 2x
where'd you get what did it look like
what did wildberry look like and just
like a little bush on the ground that
had some blueberries in it you can't
really see the blueberries let's look
right up on it but just like a little
shrub bush there
three of them over here mmm
I need two more to fill the Bears fount
of bear bellies when you collected it it
showed up so I think oh it's like an
objective item yeah it's like the
mechanical part well I'm also starving
do we have enough berries because I got
you and I thought we only need five I
don't know why we need five but are you
like dying of hunger and thirst it's
pretty close I'm gonna be real slow soon
which is a slow sign up here Bob oh this
is not where we came in before is it
yeah no it's not ranger station do you
think there might be food and one single
angle whose single dangling is that you
hear that
it's come from the right maybe this is
not a hill well maybe if you guys would
harsh what's that sound oh it's like up
on top of this plateau this is how right
which is kidnap children let's
definitely go inside wait a minute hang
on guys stop hang on guys no that's not
you don't wait no a bike guys stop a
bike Dustin jingle-jangle on its own in
the middle of the wood and the markets
fine this isn't one of your 17-story
games okay bikes don't do that I'm very
slow come to that come to the mountain
bike and eat some eat some raw beets and
potatoes well did you guys go toward
relay station to thank you you know I
can't also because my water is also I
can't get you some juice the potatoes
whoa wait is that you growling or um no
wait I'm coming I'm coming lead him to
me lead him to me lead him to me lead
him to me or not okay
you can't damage them with an axe you
could just piss them off
bro I've got a spear for you here I'm
screwed up there's a spear on the ground
there's a spear on the ground over here
wait wait you just please for the love
of God go get the spear dead weight get
alright my water bars are the way they
should head back to the boat which way
was the boat
wait can I just build a grill while
we're here can it because I could cook
some food but it's not the problem if I
had some place does anyone have plastic
on them I have plastic yes let's get
let's get over towards the shore back
the way we came
did someone did this game what it got
said did it's like food requirements get
turned up ten thousand percent because
we get thirsty so fast faster than any
other game I've ever seen
alright go towards water where's water
this way this way this way this way
are you sure oh yes this is where we
just came from I don't think this is
where we came from we were just by water
fishing for education
don't didn't the raw beets and things
give you a little bit of water cuz
they're juicy guys oh okay alright I'm
gonna go ahead already just back down
this way I'm gonna make a water thing
I'm gonna get the water going don't even
don't you worry maybe I should make a
bed how do I make a bit beds in girl
nobody well but I have to carry you back
to the bed right oh yeah god I forgot
about that mechanic in categories bed
under what is this I don't think that's
where our boat was either I don't have
enough palm leaves to craft a simple
beds palm leaves on my corpse Oh Bob
come here I got 19 palm leaves thanks
you're welcome craft a craft a little
veteran II I can't place the bed here
seriously I wouldn't have thought so
this island doesn't seem like one we can
build on well looks like we're all gonna
die friends who knew that this lovely
beautiful island was secretly a
deathtrap sucking our life
in the fence hey uh Martin how far over
here did you die
pretty high up on the mountain I could
surrender and respawn hang on let me
like carry you down to the beach as far
as I can and then it will all die in a
pile together Oh God
if we surrender in responders all our
stuff just go away or I think I guess
one of us should try it and see I'll try
and see ya here I'll see you right here
all right cool and then you you
surrender I'm succumbing to the darkness
oh ye black void of oblivion come hither
to claim my soul just come on Oh you
disappeared completely oh did you keep
your take okay mark drive the boat over
here and save in wait now oh god shark
but I have no spirit I had a lot of
metal or on me I had like all the
goodies on me I'm coming I think you're
on the complete opposite end of the
island I'm gonna die right on the right
on the coast don't worry my sweet babies
babies wait down here with me
wait can you ask this for inventory I
don't think so no please I need to
reverse the ship pattern our reverse II
I got this guys I got this I gotta do a
three-point turn with the boat but I got
it it's good that the steering wheel is
conveniently close to the
everything for my inventory so I could
just die and know no consequences to go
up once you started these five sets of
ladders two sets of stairs it's fine
don't worry about it we've got a great
system because the view at the top is
just spectacular the view is great right
it really is it really is something you
know all right well yeah I'm gonna do it
honest I think I'm gonna go to round
this thing to the other side of the
island
I think you're just on the exact
opposite side that's what I think I'm
here with you my friend and never mind
you wait still over there don't worry
I'm gonna try to scoop up some of these
retires plank yeah I'm gonna scoop up
some of these on the way you feel really
powerful up here right it's a good spot
isn't nice yeah I'm just gonna know I'm
driving we might run out of gas I'm
driving through the debris mark there's
no planks oh my god Wade please just die
and come help no no no no okay then you
lose all I got some planks mark no
thanks to you God you know as much as I
would love to harp on the the steering
wheel being up here this is a
magnificent unbelievable it's so nice
it's incredible really everyone thought
I was mad when I did it
really yeah who knew you were just a
visionary I must have to see things the
way I do to really appreciate it what is
it like being a genius of your magnitude
honestly it's hard sometimes I can be
really real with you for a minute
I bet what's it like being a genius of
your magnitude Wade hungry why is no one
asking me expert I yeah it's kind of
surprising that you can't extra duck
considering literally all three of my
bars door at zero and flashing red don't
worry we're coming Marc's slightly
driving away from the island but no I'm
sorry supplies or not I knew on supplies
mark and you're not doing anything to
help me with that
oh my god thank God we have these nets
that's all I have to say
I'm gonna miss that one there you gotta
you gotta you gotta you gotta you get oh
no it's in my hand now I don't like that
see I'm doing the hard work this better
be the beach that he's on just over here
it better be if it's not I'm going to
drive this into the nearest iceberg it's
not a boat it's a raft okay iceberg is
only six boats damn it you're right
again
God your wisdom just outshines my wit I
see a bridge you see up at the top and
that crevasse there's like a drawbridge
kind of thing oh yeah you guys need
water bottles and food with that I
forgot we could make that were idiots oh
yeah this is not a beach Damon don't
worry Wade we'll get there it's gotta be
like around the cut I'm off about to die
I'm trying to scoop up material so you
can get mining of material thank you I
don't even need what do I need right now
we just need to give back to wait that's
all we need the Sharks coming in where's
this goddamn Beach how big is this
stupid what do you even call this it's
an island what do you mean what do you
call this no with its sheer faces is
still an island yes mark you might need
water yes I do just good let me die I'm
just gonna die we have water and stuff
don't want to waste it if I just die and
respawn it'll be fine
waters off literally I'll just die dense
dense dense little chair I bet what it
was is if I went the other way around
the I bet if you went the other way we'd
be there already this is my fault this
is my fault they can see that how could
you I don't know like a site shouldn't
be up here's the thing
the power went straight to my head and I
took advantage of the situation and my
friends and I am sorry well I certainly
get that why do you think I made myself
such a majestic it's so high up captain
mark thank you thank you
you could fall into the engine and die
yes
oh no are you dying
yeah there's no pilot now yeah well I I
should probably get up wake up mark I
did wake I'm awake now I'm awake you got
the steering from now on I'm on it baby
you're on it baby you're on it maybe
I'll get some things on the grill nope
we took everything out of it
wait why you don't have any small
planters you can plant beets and
potatoes than these these guys yeah but
they're more efficient you can do three
in a small one and you'd be much more
size efficient you'd make so many more
because you cannot do three in a small
one I thought this was the most
efficient planter no no the small ones
are for beets and potatoes these are for
watermelon and pineapple
oh crap and you would be no other part
yeah you know you know what shark you
unbelievable dillhole also there's no
pilot it's fine it's fine at the beach I
see you oh hey Oh mark here I was trying
to do this I'm cooking new potatoes once
babe what would you do with all the like
the davia die da ba die like wood oh
it's in me you need some of that if you
got some I would take some I'm gonna
redo your plant situation why are the
engines off or they can you put some
wood yeah no no no it's fine because
we're almost here we're just gonna Park
it anyway might as well turn we actually
are going the right way
we have sales we have sales yeah we're
going we're coming ways with the sales
it's more they behind before we get
there because I'm hungry
see give me the giraffe tell him to keep
dancing I don't like the way he speaks
like a love song in Reverse I don't like
the way he speaks he dresses like a
monster man he reeks all right I've got
a takeover chef job everybody who's like
I can't believe we'd die we all die I
can't fight it I
I didn't die we all died they didn't die
we got an anchor was there any more food
sir yeah I just cook potatoes here take
these cookies take those I'll put the
anchor down dad are the vultures coming
free I Huck way down in the bed did my
stuff I threw on the beach stay on the
beach it did not when I died it's gone
we're out of a date wait no we're out of
potatoes my stuff on the beach is gone
so when you die even if stuff is no
longer in the inventory where you were
boned so all the bear meat I had is gone
anything I had a value was gone then
serious problem do we have a fishing rod
or would still miss you we have some
planks I can I can fish I mean are
marking fish if you under the food stuff
one of us could go onto the island look
for tiny trees I don't have an ax know
there are mangoes which is good because
I think we can we cannot never mind
can't plant mangoes wait wait there's
beets on the tape are this protects the
beets on the table here yes there is
look at that oh my god we're saved
reserved all right I'm gonna go onto the
island I guess we say you go I'll stay
here I'm gonna make food when will you
come back we're gonna have so much food
wait no mangoes you needn't tip to get
beggars you need to eat the mangoes and
then you get the seen you get the mango
seeds no I didn't get the seeds but
there were watermelon seeds yeah we
should have some seeds for stuff you can
plant somewhere ok we're saved everybody
markula fishing pool yes actually
there's one in the jug here I can start
fishing up a storm while I'm waiting for
these crypts to Griffin I don't know why
you don't trust me to take care of the
food mark we're in such a good place on
food oh yeah you went mad with power
that happened that was a thing I'm
allowed to do stuff sometimes ok you
whack me for three straight streams you
did but you also went mad
with power Oh Matt's a little mean I
don't know this is the bigger scarier
one oh this is the big big boy yeah this
huh
berries we do have berries I just don't
know where the thing is for it
it's over here Oh use all right I just
did the five wild berries soon to be
hunted or nope doesn't like that how you
guys doing ooh I'm gonna die all right
oh Jesus my health is so low yeah I'm on
literally it's true that one's not a
huntable one or something maybe you're
all just too wimpy I think we need to go
back the other way anyway wait yeah
perfect
there's a whole cave here Bob oh it's
guarding a cave yeah I wish we had some
lights and whatnot mushrooms that all
sounds really nice what you got going on
there well there's no food so I got a
machete and a blueprint for a machete
sounds really cool at sounds very very
nice I wish I was there with you this
cave is a lot bigger Bob than I think we
thought it was I can't see anything do
you need a head like it's another accent
I think it just curves around Oh God
okay oh god oh god oh god oh god
yeah the bear is just over there oh god
okay mark all right it's fine I don't
have a spear oh the shark okay let me
run back in toss mark a spear if you
could that'd be big ly appreciated
is there any cooked food so I can go
back out uh not yet but there will be
that's what I like to hear as soon as
those potatoes are done you could take
the potatoes I mean honestly I think the
potatoes are better for the stews than
just cooking the fish is what we should
be focusing on for food probably the
moment eat the goddamn potatoes do you
have a metal fishing rod at a little one
eat to the god damn potatoes and be
goddamn thankful that someone made you
goddamn bow down someone who used to be
the resident cook and many many play
throughs ago do you have a metal [ __ ]
fishing pole yeah I got em L and you
know what else I got this take it and go
alright crews might be so much we're not
fighting we're cooperating cuz he's
gonna take these potatoes ease could eat
them are we imbeciles
No
we might be imbeciles wait if you have
any extra food I don't have any food and
I'm starving to death at the moment it's
a one-second Oh who's in charge of food
in this place these potatoes are ready
get them off my grill I need wood to
cook I have no wood no wood to cook
makes Marquis a dull boy no one here
makes mark your dull boy the water the
crops crops like water the crops crop
the wall I got Bruno saw apparently what
are the crop mark has this under control
yeah another fishing pole in home oh no
no you go explore I need would you go
chop trees Oh No Marc's doing so well
I'm fine fish
I got tilapia I need no help it makes
this jump will I die if I don't
oh I'm gonna die no no no that's fine
water caught me
I'm sure I'm coming back I need food
mostly okay we gave you food food I'll
stop giving me palm fruits and little
baby fish give me the catfish could be
the salmon give me the same it see Sam
give me the same in that's beer or
something right it's done it's getting
dangerously close to our engines we if
we don't have enough to get closer to it
we're gonna be in big trouble we might
need to like motor around because there
are not a lot of trees left yeah we go
as much as I love this island we can
always come back to it because it was on
the it was one of the signals right yeah
yeah what was that that might have been
me bumping my microphone ouch so scary
oh sorry oh so scary someone might need
to like come find me I don't know if I'm
gonna make it all the way back oh no all
right let me get water no head your way
what do you need Bob food food I have
mushrooms but I don't want to eat the
mushrooms I want to keep the mushrooms
yeah and see if we can grow them or
whatever yeah mushrooms would be good
food we have like a recipe that uses
mushrooms so no I at least want to like
see if that's that's the thing mushy
stew
I'm gonna head out trip on Bob a beer
back Bob I can't stand it not refill my
water I'm gonna die now five water
machines if I have to come get the both
of you I'm gonna be very upset how long
does it take to cook a goddamn catfish a
while mark I thought you were gonna be
the chef master I am you want me to stop
me obviously not
yes what I thought oh [ __ ] I gotta go
back and get water then I'll be back for
you Bobby
okay you were just at the water water
splashing that's what I said well I had
to fight another bear I mean before you
left the boat and then at the first time
when Wade you said oh I'm out of water
why didn't you just turn back then there
was no a decent amount of water left but
fighting the bear apparently took all my
water all right that's fair what is this
what is this mango seed perfect love it
you love to save it plant the stuff mark
doesn't be a fit in the big ones it
doesn't go it doesn't go going to get
fall not dying cuz my food and water
looks great the best I've looked since
birth and even then I was an ugly ass
baby do you wanna see pictures of me as
a baby I do not know okay okay Oh mango
tree mango tree yeah my chespin told me
to tell you that for a while but I found
Bob hey man being carried is really
unpleasant yeah it's kind of kind of
janky just a little bit I'm putting some
food in this chest Bob well there's
already food here yeah I hate what do
you think I've been not doing anything
are you working.i yeah why are you all
surprised that of course I don't work
what you murdered the verb nice I
murdered it I also am putting two
uncooked steaks and some mushrooms in
the food chest here all right cool I'll
figure out how to plant the mush ease
all right we are making progress and by
making progress I mean did we discover
anything of value on that Island a
little bit of machete and a blueprint
for a machete all right but did we
discover an
story-wise about the future of utopia
and how to get there now to save our
people
yeah I got a machete there is like a
Blowfish or something we may have to
kill Blowfish I think they like one shot
you know they're very lethal if I
remember right but if you kill them they
give something I don't remember what but
that might be how we get like the
explosive powder or maybe some kind of I
don't I don't know something well I
figured I remembered we didn't go to an
island like this ever I never saw this
island but we went to like little
islands with like little goats or
something on them but around the island
remember there being like deadly fish we
had to watch out for all right okay
deadly fish I'm always watching out for
deadly fish if I'm honest do you want
the machete and you have a weapon I got
I'm gonna take the machete back to the
island I'm gonna I'm gonna go find
things do things
alright cool I'll be here with no wood
oh you need some wood I would love some
wood here you go buddy thanks buddy
alright this time we're gonna find some
stuff for suresies sir jerseys oh my god
I'm so close to dying right now
I can I can finish this bear I'm not
yeah what definitely takes longer to
kill these things so you're down yes
ladies down yeah I know I'm right next
one down this is not and I should not be
doing this boring I'm too stupid I'll
Drive the boat how about that it's
really just all circuitous to make him
only eligible to drive the boat I see oh
this a bear meets on the grill you guys
are gonna eat good steaks tonight
alright good job
folks we still have no wood but hey
that's all you wanna go get some wood I
mean I was thinking about just taking
her out for a spin with just the sail
power let's let's just let's just chug
her around that's what I'm saying
alright okay you're the captain you're
the ex I'm gonna run around and I'll
chop some of the little trees I saw
monster
thank you my god your bear are we
drifting yeah I await anchor man sail
power is not fast All Right see you guys
know all right I just don't know why
wait is it wood wood wood wood why am I
so hard to find oh the island
disappeared behind us already oh boy
oh my go ahead and crank her around for
the best I mean we could just all leave
we're buying but you know those signs
point to the research stations or
whatever aren't lying I mean I see it
but I have to parkour over toxic sludge
water to get there and I don't know that
I'm good enough for that sounds like
you're a bit of a baby
I was Lee you're a bit of a [ __ ] baby
who's not good enough how's it you're a
terrible [ __ ] baby I'm too cowardly to
do it sounds like she's like you'll
never be good enough something you don't
want us to progress in this game sounds
like you don't want us to see all the
secrets that are coming sounds like you
really don't want us to succeed wait I
crossed I don't feel so good but I
crossed would you find the ranger
station those are worth it I don't know
you cross it we didn't even know if it
was worth it it was worth it pathetic I
don't have a spear no no no husband can
now research a biofuel refiner hey it
sounds awesome well done Wade our Bruns
sole that's not a real thing
we are good on food my dude like we've
been there before though yeah well you
know now we're gonna be good on food
because I'm in charge this barrel is
mine what is the point baby barrel snipe
good job buddy thanks Gavin your
approval is all I ever wanted one of
three relay stations are now active okay
I did something doing stuff what are you
guys making folks I'm looking for
resources and I apparently turned on one
of the three relay stations
Wade's making move
she needs so much food I just ate almost
all the cooked beets I just add these
are terribly inefficient we really need
like meat stuff like fish and stuff yeah
if you if I get a fishing pole I can
totally fish from up here just drive the
boat and yes you want a fishing pole
that over there computer here I'll bring
you and I'll be your fish man longest
cast in him there you go
don't drop it I can fish from here this
is the best thing I've ever discovered
I'm gonna need some water soon you guys
have some water for me we have so much
water do we have so much water this
research station literally and fish
shark is dead I've killed it
I'm taking me yeah baby bye also I guess
I'll swing back around no no don't worry
about me I'll make it I'll make it I'll
make okay if only there was a way to
stop the engines up there if the
steering wheel up like a like controls
or something fine look I swang around
they ask you payday
thank you it'll be place to solve it's
time but now I need a wrench and a
hammer a Bruns wrench and I'm guessing
we get something if we come back name I
don't know why you're saying it like
that
what's his name Bruna or Braun or
something hmm
like the name of the saw it's a person's
belonging Oh
Bruns hammer okay captain Bob is coming
right around captain fish Bob that's
what I call myself when I fish
oh yeah that's a head back my water is a
problem I thought you were already
heading back I was in the cabin wait you
said like five minutes ago man my I need
water I assume that and you asked us if
we had water I assumed that meant you
were coming to get water so what
happened in between those two steps the
cabin oh no I can't come back I have
wood and I can't I don't have planks the
credit go by the barrel nothing
I can't go by this bear with no weapon
guys I'll die don't go near a men this
is really a problem yeah cuz there's
only one way to get by him that's to get
onion nice thanks baby
I think I snuffed by the bump brilliant
they're gonna write songs about my penis
I'm so brilliant Wow what I'll be dead
very soon but I will be at the beach but
why would they write songs about your
penis specifically I don't know why
you're so focused on my penis man you
know you're right you got me there I
don't know why I am either why are we
getting why are we engines Oh guys are
you here hey nom nom nom salt water have
I have a scarecrow why is it not going
for the Scarecrow is he is he pooped no
he's fully fine he looks good shitty
scarecrow then did this bird just follow
this guy and die we're here I'm over
here okay we can't we can't that is a
risky endeavor
I will try dad well that's not why it's
risky my health is gone I'm gonna pass
out in the water with Dom about fought
stop please stop
the boat I can't go back dying
[Music]
[Laughter]